salamualikum' guys how you doing we're
here in Florida and I'm here in a town
called Dunedin I met a wonderful Imam
here so I'm like I'm sure how are you
Malik and Salaam brother how are you
this is Imam Abdul my name Dobel from
Egypt and you know what's incredible is
when you make that human connection and
he was telling me how when they first
got here continue on with that story how
they got here how the situation was and
after the before and after so let's get
into the before and then the after after
he did watch listen actually when I came
to this message it four years ago we
were invisible I discovered that we met
people and we were talking to them about
Islam and he never knew that we have a
message adhering in Dunedin and we start
to go out make some communication with
the church you know the synagogue's with
everybody and we organized something
called walk of peace we walk in for
peace
no no come no nothing but conversation
dialogue no debates no argument just we
we need to get to know one another visit
the goal because allah sunnatullah said
that in quran actually were showing
people the beauty of the Quran Allah
says woman Asano : me manda illallah
emulous 11 McCauley in any non-muslim
mean I have a lot of things to say about
this beautiful area but the meaning of
the in English who the best who's better
in his speech than the one who calling
people to Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
who's calling people to Allah Allah
Allah and making good deeds have good
actions and he says I'm Muslim I'm doing
that because I'm Muslim and this is what
my D my Islam order me to do so we
communicate to people you know with
people and we invite them to the Masjid
here and they came actually we give them
some lectures some pro shores
you know informations about Islam we
answer these questions about you know
hatred about you know about terrorism
about everything about Isis about
everything we answered the whole
questions of people and people feel so
good towards us now the difference you
know four years ago we have some enmity
you know from the neighbors become the
police form for no reason
they actually we feel that they hate us
actually you know and I understand that
this is because of the media but
eventually when we start to communicate
with those people and this my advice to
every Imam in America and every Muslim
in America try to know your neighbors
try to communicate and communicate with
non-muslims your non-muslims are your
treasure
a lost planet Allah made them for you to
be your saviours from the Hellfire if
you're gonna save a person from the
Hellfire Allah will save you save your
neck from the heifer or at least you
know there is no more hatred between
between us at least as Muslims and
non-muslims we have nothing to hit to
hit one another for and islamically
Islamically we need to know those people
and fill them about Islam and leave them
you know and to choose you know which
way you want to go through if you're
gonna be with us as Muslims you are so
welcome
if not you are so welcome it is your
choice and your judgment gonna be in the
day of judgment not today but now you
know I want to tell my brother and
everybody we are very okay we are really
fine you know we have good relationship
and you know February 4th for all
Muslims and Florida especially in Tampa
and around Tampa we have in February 4th
the walk of peace I'm gonna start here
from Dunedin and two o'clock we're gonna
work together with non-muslims please if
you can talk to people nicely about
Islam join us we're gonna walk those
people and we're gonna try to tell them
about what we are doing in this Masjid
answer these questions try to get them
to our message and that week after
inshallah we can have a dinner and we in
of course we accommodate everybody we
will come everybody thank you very much
and may Allah bless you all Baraka love
even you see the power the human
connection
they went out knocking on door saying
come come visit us hang out with us eat
with us and that's what happened they
start to connect with the Muslims the
fear went away and now the situation is
totally different before how it was and
now after the intro
is very informative very fun check it
out we always describe to it followed on
Instagram and Twitter and then Shaw was
very very informative are you very
important we fan Indonesia a big fan of
brother Eddie
so he's tuned in really informative and
help you get back on TV love washing the
Dean show always a full of knowledge
always learning something very
interesting topics give it a watch and
follow Allah
what's the view show